i gotta tell you like i was sort of like
what's happening with us like it was
kind of in my mind like this is
we've been together a long time now like
what's what's going on like
i was in that place in my head yeah so
gwen stefani was ready for blake shelton
to pop the question
way before he did it it's incredible to
have
a best friend like that guy on tuesday
the singer opened up about the october
proposal on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon
and admitted she was starting to wonder
when her man of five years would get
down on
bended knee it was actually pretty
magical and
um wasn't expecting it at the moment
that it happened
at all didn't have any idea nobody knew
i think he had told my dad
um on my birthday about two weeks
earlier and
i gotta tell you like i was sort of like
what's happening with us like it was
kind of in my mind like this is
we've been together a long time now like
what's what's going on like
i was in that place in my head well now
she's
totally engaged but that whole wedding
planning thing is on hold
you know since we're in the middle of a
global pandemic
it's kind of funny we have nothing
because of the pandemic we're like
it's like blake why couldn't have you
done it before now we can't have a
wedding with the past
like sitting around going okay but
really
back in october after blake proposed at
his oklahoma ranch
a source told et that gwen had marriage
on the brain
for a while gwen has been ready to tie
the knot for a long time and blake knew
this was the perfect time
blake has been the one who wanted to
take it slow in the beginning but
recently he decided it was time i don't
want to remember
what i was like before gwen actually if
that answers your question
the source added quote during the
pandemic they've had
lots of down time together and he truly
saw the importance of spending life with
the person you love
somebody that is let's see
humble kind down to earth
selfless talented on the top of their
game
should i keep going i think i'm his
biggest fan so well
blake was ready and the proposal story
is pretty cute
out of nowhere he just has this ring
that's like in a cabinet when i opened
it he's like oh get the fire starter and
i'd like
open the cabinet and there's this ring
there and i'm like are you serious
it was pretty like what and we both
started bawling and
he did everyone was in shock and it
seems for this couple
mixing business with pleasure works
[Music]
not only have they found success with
collaborations like happy anywhere
but gwen also revealed that blake gave
her the unique idea for her latest music
video for
let me reintroduce myself blake was the
one that said you know that song
let me reintroduce myself that song
that's a hit he was the one he's like
you should like he called me
um driving to the airport and was like
you should dress up
as you in all your old looks and do this
video and i was like
whoa that's actually a really good idea
look at all these looks it's
genius
you